sorry hello everyone uh my name is
George post uh I'm the chief scientist
of the complex adaptive systems at uh uh
ASU I'm pleased to be uh part of this
presentation uh there will be a Q&A at
the end of the presentation and uh hold
all questions or use the chat function
and I'll do my best to answer those at
the end forly uh declared interests uh
the slides are available on my website
there but also additively they are on
the PDF uh for the conference uh itself
uh I'm going to talk about the general
challenges of dealing with a complex
late onset multigenic disease like
cancer but part of the progression of
Medical Science of course I I with some
reference to alliteration I refer to it
as Healthcare having moved from
superstitions to the monitoring of
health or disease in terms of symptoms
where we're still largely but in the era
of molecular biology and molecular
medicine clearly the ability to begin to
map disease in terms of molecular
signatures is now uh the general
trajectory for research progress the
logic is of course that moving from The
genome uh to the various omix I've just
happened to show proteomics but it is
cly how is the information in the genome
uh used to construct the molecular
Pathways and networks that constitute
the informational signaling mechanisms
within each of the differentiated cell
types within the body and then at the
same time with the comparison between
the normal and the disruptive in terms
of disease what are the causal
relationships between the perturbations
in those signal in networks and then of
course into the era of precision or what
many people call personalized medicine
what is the uh changes which have
occurred in particular individuals and
the implications of that both for their
disease uh the diagnosis and treatment
selection so as we map those causal
perturbations in molecular pathology it
is in the respective of which omix
domain you live in uh genomics
proteomics glycomics Etc the we now
begin to see that diseases even if they
originate in a single cell type or the
same organ are in fact reflecting
different perturbations in molecular
networks that give rise then to subtypes
of disease and the task then is in
therapeutic terms as to whether or not a
target for a particular drug whether a
approved or in investigation or clinical
trials is present in that
particular patient's tumor we of course
moving from an era in which Diagnostics
have moved from a uni analy situation to
large complex Multiplex profiling to
define the type of uh molecular pathway
Network defined on the right hand side
there with the blast black asteris
indicating points of potential
perturbation in that Network where the
asteris can either be used uh for
Diagnostic potential or that that
represents a potential Target uh in the
disease so in short the aphorism right
drug for the right disease subtype as a
result of molecular profiling successes
have clearly emerged over the past
decade and should be deservedly
applauded starting with her septin uh
and most recently approved by the FDA
Peta uh for breast cancer uh Zori
directed against the eml4 ALK mutation
in nons small cell lung cancer uh K
mutations in color rectal cancer B 600
mutations uh in melanoma and this of
course is not confined solely to
oncology even though oncology has been
in the Vanguard uh here's a recent
example of the cystic fibrosis
transporter protein where a specific
mutation is targeted by the uh drug uh
kico uh the targeted oncology
Therapeutics where your profiling or
stratifying patient populations is now
very much the norm you can see the
cancers listed there and the target uh
that is altered in that and then the
importance of that Target being present
uh for the utilization of those
particular therapeutic agents shown uh
in the far column so all of this of
course as you've heard in some of the
other lectures in this series is the
foundation for precision or personalized
medicine so starting there on the left a
whole repertoire of new analytical and
bioinformatics capabilities to be able
to analyze the molecular networks what
does that then mean in terms of how that
information is used for molecular
Diagnostics and disease subtyping how
far are those biomarkers multilex
biomarkers used to develop targeted
therapies and ideally of course one is
hoping in all therapeutic interventions
that you improve patient outcomes and in
a Health Care system that must pay
increasing attention to cost
uh achieving improved outcomes at lower
cost molecular Diagnostics the acronym
which will come up MDX so tumor
profiling now provides the intellectual
Foundation of rational care no longer
one size fits all subtyping of cancers
based on the underlying molecular
profile going to the third bullet there
permits you to have rational selection
of drug based on the presence or absence
of a Target in a patient tumor and I
would also emphasize absence because you
do not then give a drug to a patient
that will be of no benefit to them
that's futile for the patient it's cost
for the Health Care system and in agents
that we know have serious adverse event
profiles even Elimina in exposure when
the target is not present uh is not only
ethically responsible it's also the
basis of rational medicine uh what I
think will follow in increasingly is if
we identify where therapy is futile both
in terms of cost saving and impact on
quality of life for the patient the
acronym Q I think what we will see is an
increasing shift to focus on Optimum
therapy plus an ethical shift to
increase use of paliative care when no
drugs are available for that patient
whereas today we're all too often
continueing still to treat patients with
drugs and indeed a rather sober in
perspective a large number of cancer
patients are still put on new
therapeutic regiments even in the last
two weeks of their life a point I'm
going to come back to because we really
must fulfill that last bullet how do we
monitor response for early detection of
drug resistance so that we can identify
more agile adaptive changes in
Therapeutics or if it's not logical to
give a particular therapeutic recommend
pation uh that is still an area where
much remains to be done but it's a
cardinal requirement for progress in the
uh molecular uh uh the
Therapeutics so the the whole purpose of
disease subtyping and targeted therapy
of course as shown there is the right
selection of the right drug or the right
combination regimen for the right
disease subtype ideally to improve
clinical outcomes be more cost effective
in eliminating futile therapy as I've
already emphasized but a critical ISS
issue is reducing the high failure rate
of investigational drugs and clinical
trials by selecting patients that only
have the Target that we know that that
particular drug is acting on logically
that should lead to faster and cheaper
trials we need to think about new trial
designs the so-called adaptive or basket
trials it should lead to Greater
regulatory Clarity because you're
selecting your patients orbe it with a
recognition that the molecular Market
will go into the label for that drug the
key issue then is if you've got much
greater likelihood of getting a
guaranteed positive outcome because
you're using targeted care against
patients who've been molecularly
profiled for the target for that drug
will you in fact get premium pricing
So-Cal pay for performance the acronym
p4p that's the positive side of the
equation on the other hand we still have
the ugly reality that almost 600,000
Americans uh died to canc from cancer in
2012 and of course it is as shown on the
right hand side there uh the metastatic
propensity of tumors uh that is the
challenge here and we're going to be
spending a lot more time on that the
numbers are far from uh pleasing in so
far as here's a paper reference at the
bottom that you'll see each of the major
malignancies uh are increasing anywhere
between 20 and 30% projected increase by
2020 that's for the most part uh the
demographics of Aging like myself the
baby boomer cohort is at hand and just
the
demographics of the Aging an aging
population dictate that these rather
sobering numbers are something we're
going to have to face up to both
therapeutically and economically and
here's another paper from the Journal of
National Cancer Institute shows that we
would we will more than double the cost
of Cancer Care as a consequence of those
projections I would also draw your
attention if you can see the slide there
that much of that cost is also incurred
in the last year uh of life and that's a
difficult ethical issue that I think
we're going to have to come to terms
with for its economic as well as its
ethical uh implications and many
observers would say that 207 billion the
66% increase is in fact a highly
conservative issue and if you look at
the macroeconomics of healthcare at
large you've also got the parallel rise
of neurod degenerative diseases like
Alzheimer's occurring in parallel we're
going to have to have some very serious
debates about cost effectiveness of care
so the many learned bodies professional
societies The Institute of Medicine of
published numerous papers on what we
need to be doing better in Cancer Care
the last one one shown there uh larger
on the left hand side delivering
highquality Cancer Care should be
obligate reading for everyone in the
cancer Community because it basically
says we can be doing a lot better and in
many instances we are not doing that
well that shouldn't detract from the
deserved successes that we spoke about
earlier but uh complacency should not be
the norm here we've really got to think
long and hard about what we need to be
doing better because to many drugs fail
that's both drugs which are approved as
well as drugs failing in clinical trial
to many of our biomarkers that we think
are markers for drugs or disease
prognosis uh fail and clinical trials
are too expensive and too long and as
you would have heard from my colleague
Dr Barker yesterday anything up to a
billion or a billion plus is the cost of
now bringing a drug to Market and with
high failure rates uh that is uh
something that we really need to redress
also the cost to the Health Care system
so here is data even from
2010 uh it's really the red we need to
focus on because that's the fraction of
patients receiving those particular
drugs who do not respond to those drugs
you see glec uh for chronic myogenous
leukemia at the very top there that's a
superb response but in far too many
instances we're seeing more than 50% of
our patients not responding to those
drugs and you can see the sales of those
drugs even in
2010 uh the failures are not only
prevalent but very costly so purpose of
my lecture is the fact that I'll be a
little provocative I think we've really
got to start rethinking the cancer
problem in a very serious way
conceptually technically how do we
organize to address some of those issues
many of these challenges like many other
are cultural and also public policy
issues in relation to approve review and
approval of anti-cancer drugs and
Diagnostics and their reimbursement will
be a critical
issue so stating the obvious to this
audience as you've heard repeatedly
throughout this Symposium cancer is a
formidably complex catalog of changes in
the genome which then lead to massive
disruptions in cellular molecular
signaling Network
we could show this same slide for any
one of the major malignances but this is
nons small cell lung cancer we've gone
from top left where we just simply said
it was non-s small cell lung cancer then
subtyping the emergence of subtyping
based upon histology and now as the pie
chart shows molecular profiling
subtyping uh non-s small cell lung
cancer depending upon the uh driver
mutations which are present in a
particular particular patient and as we
showed earlier uh drugs like cotb for
from fisa for a EML for out patients but
they're only 4% of lung cancer patients
it's great if you happen to be one of
that 4% but the remaining 96% would not
then respond uh to that uh albeit superb
drug copy number alterations uh
reference shown there from the journal
of clinical oncology uh look at the top
there the most extravagant is Cirrus
ovarian carcinoma with more than F
almost 50% of the genome subject to some
measure of uh alteration but it is this
formidable catalog of genomic
alterations we're dealing with because
this slide so left hand slide just we
could show this to any any of the major
malignances but what has come to be
known as malignant snowflakes just as
snowflakes themselves are unique at the
crystalline level also increasingly we
have to face up to the fact that tumors
a little like this although there may be
a dominant catalog of driver mutations
there is also as each of those dot shows
there that's merely meant to be almost a
scatter plot showing how many mutations
are present on the other side the green
and the red means that green is a target
for a drug is present red means that a
Target is not present and so the whole
issue here is tumor heterogenity and
although people tend to talk about tumor
cell heterogenity if it's new I'm a
little stunned by that given the fact
that we've had the literature now over
four decades showing clonal
heterogeneity in tumors but since many
of the population don't read the
literature that's more than 5 years old
presumably that's why those papers are
ignored but that cathis aside with
modern molecular techniques we can
clearly map that heterogenity in much
more ugly detail so here's a paper from
the New England Journal of Medicine
renal cell caroma uh top uh left is the
primary tumor itself you have zonal
heterogenity within that tumor so
different clones even in the primary
tumor and then to top right metastases
is reected from that patient and then
underneath showing the extravagant
molecular heterogenity so in short both
the primary tumor and each of the
different metastases have in fact a
different clonal composition and
obviously the implications of this for
therapy are quite
profound we somewhat glibly talk about
genes 4 I think that's dangerously
overly simplistic and with the current
hype and I use that word purposely with
regard to how whole genome sequencing is
going to be the Panacea for everything I
think that's a Lally over simplistic and
deter terministic and although clearly
many of the technical problems were
associated with whole genome sequencing
an analytical stringency will be solved
I don't have any difficulty about that
we have to look Beyond The genome
because it is not just the coding genome
as shown there in a reference to junk
DNA with the trash can it is no longer
junk we have a huge spectrum of
alterations and Regulatory networks in
the genome itself how is that translated
top uh to the top right there in terms
of the networks and how are those then
perturbed uh in
disease what we have to think about is
more than just simply genomics and the
epig genome added on top of that because
second bullet there we have to integrate
entirely different data types uh and
there all listed there so I won't uh
simply read them out but it's clear the
integration of those distinct data types
provides a better prediction of what
that molecular signaling regulatory
network is than attempting to just have
primary sequence uh data so I think
where all this leads us is how do we
redefine the way we go about cancer drug
Discovery conduct our clinical trials
and what are the implications of that
for regulatory
approval pretty provocative comment here
from Jim Watson but I would tend to
share it and uh the why are we approving
drugs that only have shown a 3month
survival benefit or in certain instances
even less it is a horrific disease none
of us know what our own personal choices
would be to a weeks life extension or
two weeks life extension but as a
societal issue coming back to some of
the economic numbers I spoke about
earlier we're going to have to have a
very serious debate in the face of a
daunting escalation of the cancer burden
in society as to how far we can go on in
the way we're going on so we have to
come to begin to understand the
complexity of the disease we're dealing
with this is a slide that could apply
equally the top bullet could apply
equally to Alzheimer's
disease understanding the perturbation
in those biological networks and what's
gone wrong in disease but in tumors
where we perhaps have the most
extravagant challenge of complexity of
all
what are what's the Dynamics of the
multiple clones that exist in the tumor
and how they change during the growth of
the tumor and in particular in the face
of therapy where you have the emergence
of drug resistant clones so here's a
rather ugly slide at one level uh here
is the question of emergence of drug
resistance to the B v600 mutant
inhibitor zalar in malignant melanoma
superb science shown on the left there
to identify the target identify with the
asteris what was a logical Target for
the drug you see then in the middle
column uh a gentleman with disseminated
millery melanoma a horrifying Prospect
uh both for the clinician but most
importantly the patient and then after
15 weeks of therapy seemingly a miracle
all of those tumors have essentially
regressed but then tragically and
horrifically after only another 8 weeks
you see a return of millery melanoma but
now with a totally different clone which
is totally resistant to that therapy and
that is the challenge uh that we face in
terms of clonal heterogenity in relation
to acquired resistance which means
acquired because the drug was the
selection pressure but in many instances
we begin to find that many of these drug
resistant clones pre-exist exist even
before therapy is initiated and here is
just some of the examples found of late
in which mutations in those particular
genes shown on the left in the cancers
shown third column gives rise to
resistance to the drugs which are listed
there and this is the omnipresent
challenge in chemotherapy and obviously
this is intimately linked to the failure
rate of drugs in clinical trials here's
a recent paper from nature used drug
Discovery and what you really need to
focus on is the uh so from top to bottom
it's early phase one all the way through
to phase three at the bottom but the
blue is oncology drugs and as you can
see they have a higher failure rate than
any other therapeutic category and if
you're failing in phase three when
you've invested hundreds of millions of
dollars this is not only threatens the
viability of companies this is also a
highly inefficient uh process the other
issue we have to start to ask is how
many drugs acting on the same Target can
the market support if you go on to the
Pharma the far Pharma site the
pharmaceutical research manufacturers of
America site they list a thousand drugs
in development for cancer 369 of which
act on tyrosine kyes uh how many drugs
can we in fact uh afford to direct to a
given Target how do we prioritize this
is just a list of recent phase three
clinical trials of anti vef agents I
don't know how many is I used to count
it up but there's certainly at least 20
to 25 failures there of different drugs
how do we continue uh to propagate this
begins to defy uh uh uh logic got a
slight hang up on a slide here there we
are because this is a challenge you may
have seen this from my colleague an
Barker yes it's a slight modif ification
of it but basically the second the
second uh column there the base state so
that is Orange is normal and then you
see the black dot namely that is a
so-called driver mutation but that's
usually a catalog of mutations not
mutation singular and what you then have
is the initiation of a neoplastic clone
that may still be subclinical in the
patient but in turn you get another
aberant clone shown in green there and
so it goes on and you have this pattern
of clonal diversification and at certain
some point that will then reach the
stage of clinical recognition but as the
that then progresses in the patient
whether it be the primary tumor or
metastases and those that primary tumor
or the metastasis being treated what you
then have is the selection of drug
resistant or as we'll come back to a
little later immune Escape variants but
in short complex clonal Dynamics and our
understanding of both clonal composition
and how those clones change during tumor
progression is still pretty much a black
box for contemporary cancer research so
it is this complex evolutionary Ecology
of tumors that is our principal
intellectual and conceptual challenge
bullet two what determines the kinetics
by which clonal diversification occurs
what determines the sequence at which
metastic clones emerge if we could
obviously catch primary tumors before
the metastic horse had left the stable
with most most places the surgeon would
be very effective in removing a small uh
premetastatic lesion that would be a
definitive cure unfortunately in far too
many cases those 600,000 patients that
we spoke of dying each year are dying as
a consequence of metastasis the next
issue is what is the balance between
random stochastic events and
deterministic events there are clearly
driver mutations as you heard in other
presentations and passenger mutations
but on the other hand passenger
mutations May in fact be important in
withstanding things like hypoxia and
acidic conditions and so forth in the
tumor micro environment and then last
bullet how does the Tuma micro
environment itself either help control
the emergence of diverse clones or
actually drive the emergence of those
clones so these are profound questions
easily posed but we do not have answers
to them because this is what we've
really got to deal with if we're going
to master uh in a more meaningful way
the complexity of clonal heterogenity we
need a top bullet there improve the
prediction by which particular networks
are disregulated disregulated and what
is the most likely drug resistant and
immune evasion Escape Pathways that any
given clone might use to escape and how
could we use that to better instruct our
therapeutic paradigms I've emphasized
earlier what happens we well even if we
profile a patient's tumor when it's
initially diagnosed and tragically not
enough patients are profiled at the time
of diagnosis how do we monitor that
patient over time to m to monitor the
emergence of clones particularly drug
resistant clones as shown in bullet 3
Because as I'll emphasize later uh we
can't go
around uh biopsy in every metastasis
both on terms of economics even if we
could find the metastases in their in
their smallest form but both for patient
quality of life as well as economics
that's not really
feasible so I think what we have have to
start thinking about is this is an
abridgement of the slide I showed
earlier we profile we find out what the
network perturbation is then on the
other side you see the asteris how do we
in fact identify what's gone wrong but
most importantly we have to think more
and more about even if those are the
points at which the network is
disregulated what is the most likely
Bypass or compensatory circuit that a
tacel clone can use to escape that
particular therapy uh the uh seem to
have gone back there my apologies so you
have to think about issues in context
too so just because a particular
mutation occurs in one tumor type it
doesn't necessarily confer
susceptibility to a particular therapy
so so here is colar rectal CER kodon 12
mutations in K Ras render that tumor
resist resistant to drugs like vectorx
and herbox on the other hand another
mutation PG13 d uh renders that tumor
sensitive moving on to melanoma in
melanoma you've seen s even though
resistance tends to overtake uh the
situation nonetheless the v600 mutations
confer susceptibility to
vapam sensitive in melanoma color rectal
tumors also Express the B v600 mutations
but the drug is ineffective in colar
rectal carcinoma because colar rectal
carcinoma bypasses it because it's got
resistant amplifies its epidermal growth
factor receptors similarly in last
Orange Box there in gastrointestinal
stromal tumors gist kit mutations if the
mutations in xon 11 the tumor is
sensitive to that dose 400 mg if the
mutation is In xon N then you need
almost double the dose with the
implications then of potential toxicity
and so forth so just because a mutation
is present it has to be interpreted in
the much larger context uh of the
network here's another example lung
cancer the wonderful response is seen in
lung cancer specific egfr mutations to
kise
Inhibitors the mutations in lung cancer
reside in the portion of the kidas which
exists in the cytoplasmic
domain other mutations occurring gleo
blastoma is shown in bullet 2 but on the
other hand the mutations there are in
the extracellular domain of the egfr
receptor and therefore uh despite the
trials that were logically done thinking
that uh something it worked in lung
cancer because egfr mutations also occur
in gleo blastoma but but because they're
occurring in an entirely different part
of the target molecule then you get
sensitivity in lung resistance or
non-responsiveness in gleo in in in gleo
blastoma so context really does matter
but I think what we've got to come to
terms with is what I call the Dead Hand
of reductionism and the trap of
linearity and what I mean by that is a
belief that somehow identification of a
single molecular Target is going to help
us solve this disease and that networks
are simply linear when they're in fact
complex and have highly linear nonlinear
uh uh components and the bottom line is
the fact that I think that we've got to
seriously start thinking about how we
think about Network pharmacology not
just single Target pharmacology and
think of it in these terms there are few
single targets for Effective drug action
if a drug or drug regime in plural is
going to require modulation of multiple
Targets in multiple Pathways and there
are no linear Pathways there are only
networks and there are also highly
interconnected networks as shown in this
slide so the in this in this circos plot
the color bands going around the circle
show the different net the different
Pathways which are linked to each other
so even if you effectively intervened in
one you've also got to effectively
intervene uh in another so what does all
of that mean I'll go past this slide uh
it means that we either have to think
about single agents which are capable of
acting on multiple
sites on a single Target and blocking uh
sorry that should be a single pathway I
apologize multiple sites in a single
pathway and block the most likely way
that pathway may be modulated to allow
the Clone to escape alternatively do we
devise drugs which are promiscuous in
the sense of hitting multiple targets I
think that's a very tall order
technically as well as controlling any
of Target Adverse Events but just even
designing a molecule with that level of
promiscuity is going to be extraordinar
difficult perhaps the most more logical
issue combining bullet 1 and bullet 3 is
designing combinations of drugs with
multi-site action or multiple targets
but then you get into the issue of how
how complex a therapeutic regimen can a
patient stand the cost of the Health
Care system and how do we design
clinical trials for large combinations
which I'm going to come to in just uh a
moment but here for example is uh uh the
the the challenge here are multi-target
Tyrus in kise Inhibitors in gleo
blastoma you can see that there's the
agent all of them hitting multiple kyes
uh but of not uh leading to the type of
therapeutic resolution you want so it
again highlights the complexity of
network pharmacology so some people are
now looking for irreversible kise
Inhibitors so the first few bullets
there Define the logic Prospect of
circumventing resistance to R reversible
chinise Inhibitors by designing
irreversible chinise uh Inhibitors uh
but then you come down to the last
bullet the discrepancy between first
class lab data and clinical data when a
fanb which is active in vitro against
resistant to reversible Inhibitors then
when it goes into the clinic tragically
does not yield the expected
results perhaps we've got to get better
in terms of Designing our screening
therapies to design uh cell populations
that do have a Fidelity with the type of
tumor related variation we see in human
cells so much of the sort of tailin and
crisper engineering for modifications of
genomes uh that may very well be
enabling us as a nice paper that's just
come out in genome research shown there
in the last bullet if if at least we
could engineer cell popular ations that
show exactly the same perturbation that
occurs in the networks that we know
occur in drug resistant cells uh to
recover from patients we may be able to
use that information more effectively uh
to design ways of avoiding immune Escape
but it may very well be that we're
intrinsically Limited in the
chemotherapeutic space and imuno
oncology May in fact be more effective
uh I think it's early day but
nonetheless the success achieved with uh
immune checkpoint Inhibitors such as
ulad uh from Bristol Mayer squib and so
forth because the issue here as many of
the audience I'm sure know is the fact
that the tumor appears to be able to
suppress the uh t- regulatory networks
that are involved ordinarily in host
defense and by activating suppressor
networks the tumor is actually able to
escape even if it has still got antigens
which are recognized by the immune
system I think that some of the data now
emerging in this domain is actually very
encouraging and it's certainly a watch
this space Arena the other issue of
course is how far does the micro
environment in which the tumor cells
exist also influence their behavior and
how far do the tumor cells themselves
influence the behavior of the micro
envir environment and so there are
particular issues here uh particularly
in relation to come down towards the
bottom uh of this the bullet list there
how far do stromal cells release
materials that actually favor tumor cell
uh survival last bullet how the tumor
cells actually then uh create epithelial
meenal transition which we know is
important in metastasis in certain
situations by precondition in tumor
micro environments interesting example
of how micro rnas uh released from the
tumor cell can in fact under the second
bullet there affecting interlukin 8 and
interlukin 8 affecting uh the tumor cell
uh suppressor uh Network so again a
black box but some light is beginning to
be sha into that box as to how the tumor
is actually able to modulate the immune
response and then of course there is the
issue of cancer stem cells uh there's uh
divided opinion about their existence
but I believe that there's accumulating
evidence to support their existence I
think we need a much more purposeful
directed is effort to resolve the issue
because if they do exist they represent
an obvious Target for therapeutic or
immune assault if stem cells exist they
exhibit more limited Renity and they
therefore therapeutically more tractable
are they in fact genomically canalized
to use the evolutionary biologist term
and have therefore less genetic
heterogenity and constrained phenotypic
het diversity which makes them more
attractive from the standpoint of
therapeutic
intervention so irrespective of what the
balance between multi-target
chemotherapy will be in the future
immuno oncology and subtyping tumors
we're going to have to redesign the way
we do clinical trials no longer one size
fits all patients have to be stratified
but how do we in fact evaluate much more
rapidly whether or not a drug or an
immunotherapy is working right now we're
for the most part trapped in imaging
methods such as resist is shown there
but that is a rather limited and rather
slow three the six months followup as to
know what is happening to a particular
drug what we must move towards is the
so-called liquid biopsy the need to be
able to monitor patients for solid
malignancies to detect the emergence of
drug resistance or immune evasion clones
whether they exist prior to therapy or
acquire that as a consequence of
exposure to therapy and also what's
mineral residual disease so we're at
least aware this patient May uh uh
relapse so here is a recent elegant
paper recovery circulating tumor cells
the green arrows there show variations
in a single cancer cell recovered
they've examined many but this is just
one cell none of those variations would
have been picked up by examining uh the
bulk
tumor the hematopoetic malignances the
leukemias and the lymphomas are easy to
sample easier to sample Le in a dynamic
sense because you've got access to the
liquid biopsy namely blood or bone
marrow and therefore individuals working
with hematopoetic oncologists working
with hematopoetic tumors can actually
practice anticipatory chemotherapy
because they can identify the emergence
of drug resistant clones before they
become the dominant clone and attempt to
stop those clones before they become uh
clinically prominent but of course in
solid tumors breast lung prostate and C
uh colon which account for 80% of all
cancer deaths you can't go around doing
a biopsy on every metastasis to profile
it we've got to find we've got to be
Innovative in the way we can in fact do
minimally invasive liquid biopsies so
whether it be circulating tumor cells
circulating nucleic acids tumor
Associated proteins the question there
is uh whether or not your the dynamic
range of proteins in the circulation is
adequate to in fact pick pick up uh
minor clones or alternatively membrane
vesicles such as exosomes I'm not
arguing for any one of those in
particular but the all of those Merit
explan uh uh exploration uh as a way of
finding more Dynamic ways to monitor
tumor progression because we've got to
move to Adaptive trials we can't just
take
all comers start monitor progression
free survival and then try and look at
overall survival I think uh things like
Laura esserman's I spy trial out at UCSF
are the prototype for the way we've got
to go namely investigating multiple
drugs and having more rapid ways to
assess whether or not any given drug or
drug combination is working at any given
time that requires however bullet three
that we've got biomarkers to assess
therapeutic response that's not always
the case the statistical designs are
much more uh complex and last bullet it
also is logistically much more complex
because you're asking multiple biofarm
companies or big Farmer for use of
multiple investigational agents
simultaneously and although that has
Logic the overall issue is the fact that
we've got to move towards that the other
issue which I think is particularly
frustrating is the fact that most
standard of care s so Therapeutics still
compromised by the emerging significant
refractory disease and the emergence of
those resistant clones but that standard
of care is a major obstacle to how we
evaluate new drugs because we if we if
we're trapped having to investigate new
investigational drugs by only looking at
treatment failure populations the the
nature of the clonal population patients
in those tumors which have progressed
and have been resistant to all forms of
therapy thrown against them they may
have little resemblance to the tumor
that existed at the outset and therefore
I think we've got to pay much more
attention to how we can use Neo adant
therapy for investigational drugs so Neo
adant therapy second bullet there
evaluating the drug prior to surgery and
assess a so-called pathologic complete
response namely what fraction of
patients at the time of surgery has
their tumor shown some measure of
response we've had an instructive
precedent in breast cancer just approved
by the FDA Peta from Ro jentech uh but
at the same time that also in addition
to allowing you to test whether this is
a meaningful drug to go into clinical
trials it also validates whether the
drug acts on the target it also permits
us to abandon
earlier drugs that have limited efficacy
or adverse event liabilities the other
issue which is an obligation is the fact
if you get accelerated or breakthrough
approval on the basis of Neo adant
therapy you should and quite
appropriately be asked by the FDA to do
a larger confirmatory trial for
progression free survival or overall
survival so I think we've got to also
Embrace a better conceptual framework
work for understanding the biology of
different types of tumors
so understandably cancer is still
perceived but most importantly treated
as a diagnosis with lethal consequences
if left untreated but it's clear that we
have subtypes of breast prostate lung
and thyroid what are known as Idle
indolent lesions that can be in place
for a very long time without being
seriously threatening so therefore
should in fact the case be made that the
term cancer be reserved for lesions
where we know we have a reasonable
likelihood of lethal progression if left
untreated uh because if we're if we're
diagnosing and treating these indolent
lesions which are not really
lifethreatening in any way we enter the
over diagnosis over treatment dilemma
one understands intellectually where
we've got there but I think this is
argued very persuasively Again by Laura
es in this paper in Jama recently
published in September and they
basically create this hierarchy uh of uh
rankings so what you can see there in
the top for breast prostate and certain
tumors of the lungs and bronchus we've
dramatically increased the incidence in
terms of effectiveness of diagnosis but
on the other hand mortality is remained
constant suggesting that the change
we're seeing uh is in fact due to
overdiagnosis and over treatment of
indolent lesions you move then to the
next two boxes where you've got tumors
of much higher consequence colon and
cervical we've seen in the green box
there we've achieved much more because
of the effectiveness of colonoscopy and
Pap smears in identifying those lesions
before they become premetastatic and
then of course you move to tumors in the
red box where you can see that the
incidence is high
but the mortality uh is is unchanged
indicating that we're not really
effectively getting to grips with those
tumors so in the last part of my talk I
just want to talk about some of the
other issues we're going to have to
wrestle with in this space so
irrespective of which ohms you study the
genome all the way through to what
constitutes the phenome what are the
environmental factors the so-called
exposome we have to evaluate all of
these data sets but undou
uh a somewhat overused word but I'm
going to call it Big Data and how do we
build the infrastructure for dealing
with that uh I think my colleague Anne
Barker may have shown this yesterday but
it's what I call V5 data vast increases
in data volume the speed of acquisition
of that the variety of that data but I
think we've got an increasing challenge
to ensure that that data is accurate
there's increasing recognition that much
of the academic Discovery literature is
somewhat sloppy and not reproducible but
the overall issue for clinical
translation is does it confer value and
if we're going to deal effectively with
these very large data sets what is the
computational infrastructure how do we
integrate them how do we profile the
analytics and equally important how do
we educate and train healthc Care
Professionals to be able to use the data
a paper well worth reading from uh the
group out at UC Santa Cruz
on just everyone talks glibly about uh
sequencing tens thousands hundreds of
thousands of cancer genomes this is a
very audite and pragmatic analysis of
the logistical challenges involved in
handling that type of data set the other
issue is what I call silos subvert
Solutions and we're all all at risk of
living in those but I like this quote
from TS ell Elliot hell is the place
where nothing connects so welcome to
healthcare and that is the fact that
these are the various
constituencies research and Discovery
generates data how do we move that
effectively in Translation on into
clinical trials and then in health care
delivery how all of those are
constituencies that need uh to be
involved we have to think about how do
we make our data be able to move from
the left hand side all the way through
to the right in formats which are
interoperable scale ailable extensible
can be used by those different
constituencies at the
end clearly electronic medical records
and and health information records are
The Logical way to go but for the most
part all we're doing is to replicate
paper records
electronically right now the formats for
those records are completely
incompatible with logical assimilation
of contemporary molecular medicine
social media data and so forth and there
are legitimate privacy and security
protections which are coming up as
barriers I think those can be
circumvented but unless we begin to
devise interoperable extensibility and
flexibility in our electronic medical
records then all of this extraordinary
work in the discovery domain will not be
translatable to clinical trials yet
alone into direct patient care and then
we have the growing education and
knowledge Gap in Concepts in molecular
medicine not just in oncology uh amongst
Health Care Professionals I think this
is a major Gap that is going to bite us
in the future how do we engage patients
more effectively clearly we've seen
courtesy of social media and patient
activism uh a a change in dimension I
suspect is intergenerational the young
are certainly not going to tolerate what
my generation has uh taken in terms of
paternalism
in healthcare we're seeing patient
groups and this is only a couple of them
the love Army of women patients like me
many others could be actively uh shown
uh being much more actively involved and
I think we have to think about where all
of this takes us so I've been purposely
provocative because I think that 600,000
cancer deaths a year means that while we
should applaud the successes we have
much more to do this is another way of
putting Watson's question what is a
meaningful advance in therapeutic
Effectiveness can we continue to afford
to approve drugs that cost $80 to
$100,000 I'm not arguing against the
price per se but for only a few weeks or
even a few months uh uh uh uh survival
it's a question which is clearly fraught
with ethical and legal complications but
the debate will have to be engaged
because it isn't just about science it's
also about policy and cost and
outcomes The Institute of medicine
report referred to earlier we're doing
more but not necessarily doing better
because we have a buy and Bell situation
in which oncologist Financial incentives
are not aligned with quality of care and
what do I mean by that these two circles
show where we're making progress in
molecular
Diagnostics we talk about companion
Diagnostics but should really be
companion Therapeutics because we're
using Diagnostics to say which drug a
patient should or should not get That's
The Power of contemporary molecular
biology to enable us to profile a
patient but then on the other side one
size fits all for the most part is still
the standard of care when we know that
we've got subtypes of tumors that can be
profiled so in the gray boxes we have
molecular Diagnostics representing the
scientific foundation for precision
medicine and rational treatment and on
the other hand we've got still Legacy
standard of care that propagates
irrational therapeutic strategies which
have limited Effectiveness but it all
comes down as so much in medicine to how
it gets
reimbursed we're seeing extremely myopic
postures taken by CMS with regard to
reimbursement for molecular Diagnostics
cost based reimbursement what should be
the value of a diagnostic that says a
patient should get $100,000 treatment
because they're going to respond but
equally withhold that treatment because
that patient isn't going to respond
that's value based pricing but that's
not being practice so what we have going
to the left hand side is uncritical
acceptance of therapeutic pricing and
incentives to sustain flaw Discovery uh
as a consequence because you're failing
to reimburse on the right hand side of
that so we have an uncritical acceptance
of the high price of new Therapeutics
which are often in many instances
offering marginal gains we're seeing
slow adoption by the clinical Community
to identify and profile responder versus
resistant patients but the economic
incentives are oncologist to profile
patients are misaligned with profiling
and current Regulatory and reimb urement
policies don't address that challenge
because think about it 60 to 80% of
oncologist income is tied now to
reimbursement from
Therapeutics what we have is a pricing
structure that permits purchase at 80%
of the average wholesale price and
reimbursement of
106% slow updating of standard of care
guidelines we see increasingly lack of
adance to standard of care and as I've
mentioned earlier overaggressive use of
new therapeutic regimens in the last two
weeks of life with no impact on clinical
uh benefit and huge cost so in
conclusion I would argue we've got to
come to think in a much more
sophisticated way if we're really going
to innovate we've got to integrate in a
much more sophisticated way and has
always been the case in science and
medicine Innovation demands boldness and
I think we're trapped in incremental
timidity at the present time first of
all what's the relevance of our
models I think that there's great
cultural and organizational barriers to
change for quite understandable reasons
the bottom line is the fact that if
you're in Academia promotion and tenure
is very much dependent upon uh uh Grant
acquisition and publication which
doesn't lend itself to the abandonment
of models or the or the EXP exploration
of new arenas
is the massive investment we now make
both public and in the commercial sector
in new anti-cancer drugs directed to a
single Target or a single pathway
intellectually flawed when we already
know what we're dealing with in terms of
disregulation of complex networks an
even more sobering question nasty but
largely ignored is is the scale of
molecular
disregulation in advanced metastatic
disease so extreme that therapeutic
circum intervention and restoration of
network stability namely
homeostasis even via action at multiple
sites in multiple Pathways May in fact
be
unattainable I think that there is a
thin line between hype and hope this is
not a criticism of these organizations
because they're well intentioned but I
think that they create a false sense
that if we just throw more money at this
problem without thinking more deeply
about the problem all will be well I
don't think celebrity populism and
belief that more money will solve
everything is correct I think we need to
fundamentally reassess why therapeutic
success against metastatic solid tumors
the hematic tumors are a different
matter remain so elusive I think we have
to face up to cancer is a complex
adaptive systems that requires major
changes in our approaches to both
Discovery uh and clinical oncology I
would submit that perhaps returns from
multi-billion investments in cancer
research directed to drug Discovery
could be better balanced I'm not arguing
to cut off drug Discovery but realign
some of that to Accord higher priority
to robust biomarker tumor profiling that
permits earlier detection of
consequential tumors with before they've
metastasized in short robust separation
of the indolent tumors versus the
consequential tumors therefore getting
to grips with the overt treatment of low
risk uh disease how do we monitor clones
the liquid biopsy Challenge and how do
we better predict how tumor cell clones
May Escape as a way of guiding new drug
Discovery so in short cancer is a
complex adaptive system how do we de
deconvolute that complexity but
multi-dimensional problems won't be
solved by unidimensional Concepts in
short silos subvert Solutions many of
you may have heard an Barker my
colleague here at ASU Anker yesterday
here's a quote from Anne in 2008 the
cancer biology Community is unprepared
to solve the difficult transdisciplinary
problems so it's as much organizational
before we get to grips with the
technical problems and I think she's
absolutely right are we yet sufficiently
engaged we need to think about this in a
much more sophisticated integrated
endtoend way build new capabilities in
Cross disciplinary research whether
people like it or not this begins to be
big science and Big Data new types of
clinical trials and even though most
academic research is still oriented to
individual investigators we've got to
think much more about team-based uh
Discovery new patterns of collaboration
and intellectual fusion and yes it
carries profound implications for both
the way we teach the way we do research
the way we create business models and I
would argue that the siloed structure of
Academia industry and government is now
a major obstacle to mobilizing many of
these issues with none of us like change
I like this slide with acknowledgement
to its source there change is good you
go first but I think that the
unacceptable nature of what we're facing
in cancer dictates we have to so I would
hope that at some point and that this
may be some small contribution towards
it resistance to change Must Fall
against uh necessity I would argue that
nothing in what I've said should be
detract from the great successes that
have been made but that should not be a
predisposition to complacency or a
failure to address the the real
challenges ahead of us that relate to
the intrinsic biological complexity so
thanks for your attention uh I know it's
been a superficial surf across a broad
swath of material but now be happy to uh
answer any uh
questions so it's an eye test for me
here reading this
uh
I'm just going to move off camera for a
second that's a question appears to be
cut
off as sorry I've got a question here
that it it
reads uh thanks to the presentation I
noticed that uh AR index is only 10%
affected with breast cancer patients and
then unfortunately the rest of the
question uh is is uh cut off what is a
more effective drug I hope that's the
full question again I think that thank
you for the question it really depends
upon obviously as I've been talking
about there is no such thing now any
longer as breath breast cancer it's
multiple subtypes of breast cancer so
the question of what any given patient
has relative to the molecular profile or
subtype of that patient so as I said
earlier starting with her septin a
patient who has uh you know her to new
uh receptor will respond to that drug uh
but an individual who lacks that
receptor will not so it will very much
and that's obviously just only one of
many one of the Great challenges in
breast cancer the so-called triple
negative patients who have no uh
modulation of of several hormone uh
receptors so U I'm sorry I can't answer
your question definitively but the key
issue is what subtype of breast cancer
uh uh is is involved the second question
is uh we need to change but where to
begin uh in the era of big uh data uh
again I think that the I if I had a
magic wand uh it would simply be that
data has to be reproducible we've got
far too much of the basic cancer
research literature is not
reproducible I would even like to see a
situation which I know won't be
implemented that that paper shouldn't be
published unless it's been reproduced by
at least two Labs working together I
think in terms of big data per se as I
said in one of the earlier slides I
think we have to find new file ways of
linking genomic data with proteomic data
with clinical phenotypic data uh
epigenetic data is in there uh so in
short multiple data streams have got to
be integrated but again it comes back to
the basic research Community unless
we're beginning to adopt standardized on
standardized ontologies for the
description of our data standardized
data reporting methodologies all we're
doing is creating ass series of data
tombs or data silos that that data
cannot be integrated if we get that
right then we can start to integrate
those data sets at the patient end
however we should be able to leverage
healthc care data in a much more
proficient way part of it is of course
the curse of the paper record how do you
pull together all of this data but
nonetheless we still have large tumor
Registries available to us to begin to
correlate outcomes with the type of
treatment used uh with the the outcome
because clearly what happens under very
controlled clinical trials is not
necessarily what happens when the drug
gets to uh a broader uh use but I think
the other issue about big data is even
if we begin to get standardized right
standards correct interoperability
Frameworks correct we've still got to
think about the question of of uh how
that integration is done how that data
is then disseminated to healthc Care
Professionals for better patient
decisions and again coming back to the
Discovery end do universities have
adequate infrastructure in order to
handle these very large uh uh uh data
sets I've got another question here
sorry for jumping off
camera
I'm just going to have to expand
here so I've got an expansion of the
question have have you thought about uh
sub submolecular IE Atomic variation
that may make molecular medicine uh look
blunt uh uh Tough Enough at the
molecular level with a smiley face quite
quite right uh uh yes I think we all
think about structure activity
relationships being determined uh at the
at angstrom and uh level uh and your
question is absolutely valid uh I don't
yet think that we have adequate uh data
sets to able us to do that although that
is obviously The Logical way to go uh
with uh this this year's molecular of
Nobel Prize in chemistry being given for
advances in molecular modeling in terms
of drug uh Lian Target interactions but
as you rightly say it is difficult even
at the molecular level but we will
eventually have to go to to that level
but for the most part the data sets are
not there I'm going to take the next
question question is is there any
database or biotool currently available
from where we can access the integrated
data of a particular cancer like
leukemia uh yes there are the our
colleagues in the hematopoetic tumor
space namely the leukemia and the
lymphomas have probably got more
sophisticated databases uh than uh
people working with the solid
malignancies in no small measure because
as I said earlier it's possible to
follow patients and what happens during
tumor progression and how drug
resistance uh uh develops but again uh
it depends upon which type of leukemia
we're talking about because leukemias
have now been subtyped probably more
more profoundly than any other cancer
type at the present time so again it
would be very similar to the question I
answered about breast cancer namely that
there are M so many multiple types of
leukemia you would want to relate it to
a specific genetic change particular uh
trans locations uh uh in in
particular next question is uh single
drug for multi-target is a tot order
will you will be available to disc that
possibility with our endogenous Master
regulatory drug uh uh yep as my as as I
hope came across in my talk uh devising
a promiscuous agent for multiple targets
uh is a tall order what we do know
however certainly from areas well
outside of cancer uh in other theraputic
areas that a number of drugs which have
been approved do in fact perhaps work
because they hit multiple points in
molecular networks but to start out
denovo to say I'm going to design a drug
to hit multiple points in a network is
as you rightly say a tall order because
we in fact don't have the knowledge to
know precisely which exact multiple
points we need to hit in that Network I
think that uh we're going to have to uh
that I think promise Security in a
single agent is going to be far more
difficult to achieve than multi-agent
intervention but even there you're still
left with the question of if our
understanding the network still
represents a black box where we do not
know the most likely bypass Pathways by
which resistance or Escape would emerge
uh that still represents a deficit in in
our knowledge so uh yes uh you're right
but I don't know at this stage how we
actually know how to modulate that
Network hence why I come back to this
issue of uh trying to not only Define
tumors in the premetastatic state but at
least beginning to identify drug
resistance in as clones emerg during
tumor
progression that appears to be the limit
of the question so thank you very much
as I indicated uh slide are available on
my website uh and the uh overall issue
is the uh just come up with that last
one so slides are available there uh on
my website sh at the top there is also a
PDF through bio conference itself and
the CME questions uh have been submitted
obviously to bio conference for those of
you who are pursuing CME so again thanks
for your attention and I hope you
enjoyed the lecture
okay